Let us look at the meaning of the sentence, Ashok ate a frog.
When I say the sentence, you understand its meaning immediately. But
what did you understand? What is the meaning, of the meaning, of the sentence?
How can I capture that meaning? How we capture it in a machine? Let us focus for
now, on the verb in the sentence, which is ate. We'll associate a frame.
With the verb in the sentence. Later on we will see that frames can
also be associated with the objects or the nouns in the sentence, but for
now we will focus on the verb. Now what is it that we know about
the stereotypical action of eating? What happens when people eat, when you and
I eat? Usually there is an agent, that does the eating. And that particular
agent that corresponded the subject of the sentence. Usually something is being
eaten, that's the object. There is often a location where the eating is done or
the time when the eating is being done. Someone might use a, utensil to
do the eating. You might eat with a fork or a spoon for example. There might be
other things that we know about the stereotypical action of eating. For example,
what is being eaten typically is not alive. At least not when humans eat it.
Now this vertical slot object-is, this concerns the location of the object.
Where is the object after it has been eaten? And you might say well,
it's inside the subject's body. What might be the mood of the subject? Well,
after people have eaten, typically they are happier. So, here is
a list of slots that we associate with the stereotypical action of eating.
This is not an exhaustive list, you can add some more. So each of the slots may
take some values. We'll call these values fillers. So slots and
fillers. Some of the fillers are here by default.
Some of the fillers may come from. Parsing the sentence. So, we know that
in this particular sentence, the subject is Ashok and the object is a frog.
Okay so, frame then, is a knowledge structure. Note the word structure.
There are, a number of things happening in this knowledge representation.
If I may take an analogy with something, with which I'm sure you are familiar.
Consider the difference between an atom of knowledge representation, and
a molecule of knowledge representation. Some knowledge representations are like
atoms, other knowledge representations are like molecules.
An atom is a unit by itself, a production rule is like an atom.
On the other hand, frames are like molecules, they have a structure.
There are a large number of things happening. These molecules could expand or
could contract. You can do a lot more with frames, that you can do with a simple
production rule. So frame isn't like a knowledge structure, which has slots, and
which has fillers that go with it. Some of these fillers, are by default.
A frame deals with the stereotypical situation. Consider now a different
sentence. Suppose we had the sentence, David ate a pizza at home. Now here,
I have filled out what a frame for this particular sentence would look like.
The subject is different, the object is different. This time,
there is some information about location, in the previous sentence there was no
information about location. Let us compare these two frames for another second.
Note that these slots. In case of both the frames are exactly the same, because
the frame corresponds to the action of eating. The fillers on the other hand
are different, at least some of the fillers are different, because these fillers
corresponded the various input sentences. The only fillers that are the same,
are those fillers which have to do with default values for particular slots.